we're gonna determine now there should  be around about 20 words in here unless  some of you disobey the instructions and  wrote multiple words on one card okay so  there will be around 20 words I'm gonna  try and wrap all 20 of those words in  just three minutes  this means going to start the timer will  stop counting down when I pointed at you  are you ready to go show amazing letter  B while on a spring break it might be a  mistake  when my mother beat ya my top I like to  take off if you see me can you wanna up  sir we'll do it now round the back of  this dumpster I'll be down nice books  let me dive down as you bury me in trust  I do it  in a blackjack it's crowded you  [Music]  you know it's a big probably so see  better break  the windows down maybe oh yeah  I do it that deep dive  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]